why is it so impactful that the planets
will be i mean don't go there
yes but it's a really good question
that's the part that the skeptic
wouldn't need anything
i appreciate them no it's a it's an
abstract it's just like
you can't see love but you absolutely
know it's true
good analogy you can't see gravity but
you don't doubt that if we tip that over
it's done
we can't see electricity we still don't
know why electricity works there's still
a mystery
so this takes us to the mystery and we
have logical people that go
no if you can't well i'm sorry then you
can't do love
if you don't want to stay in love and be
able to deal with that we're going to go
past logic now and go in this room
called the right brain
if you don't want to hang out with me
good have fun by yourself that is a
fantastic argument
[Music]
i believe that each and every one of us
has the power within ourselves
to create the life that we really want
and i want to help give you the tools to
make that
happen i'm danica patrick and i'm pretty
intense
welcome to the show thank you so much
for tuning in
today's guest is deborah silverman she
is an astrologer
but she's so much more than an
astrologer she
is i mean she's very intuitive
she has a degree in psychology um and
she
is just a really fascinating human being
that has
feels like she is called here to bring
astrology
to mainstream conversation in a
conversational way
so she's what she would say i'm speaking
english when it comes to talking about
astrology
so that so that people can really
understand it and use it and i was blown
away just
well of course by how much she knew but
you know
the the the understanding of that
and how that can relate to myself as
well as of course others
so i feel like this is like a missing
huge
ingredient to how we how we approach
life
with the people that we spend time with
of course that means
our our partners our family members
our children our co-workers our bosses
our employees
i don't see how this can't help
all of those situations by just
understanding
the root of of the human being and where
they came from based on
when when they were born and where they
were born and how all the stars the moon
the sun
everything is lined up and i'm just it's
just
honestly it's it's mind-blowing how
accurate it is
so please pick up deborah silverman's
new book called the missing element
inspiring compassion for the human
condition
i have no doubt that it will change your
life just as meeting her
has now changed mine and i just you are
um obviously an amazing woman like so
many talents and gifts
and it's fun to sit here with you
my love of astrology goes way back to
buying linda goodman's love signs books
it goes back to getting a reading on my
18th birthday in
england because random yeah like i just
have
always been interested in it and i think
that when i
when i look at the where i'm at now
spiritually and what i'm interested in
and what i've dove deeper into
it makes total sense all the stuff that
i did when i was a
teenager late teenager it's showing up
now so
i might have been dipping my toe in with
buying a love signs book to see if i'm
compatible with somebody
but you don't do that if you're not
curious
and so um anyway i i'm so excited to be
sitting here
thank you thank you for inviting me and
this is my mission this life is to bring
astrology into a modern language where
we can talk about it
because it's in the zeitgeist it's been
there for 5
000 years like this is the oldest
science on earth
and every magazine and every newspaper
now all over online
everyone talks about they don't really
know what they're talking about but
there's this fascination
why because it's been in the
consciousness of our
the architecture of our minds are built
around
these 12 archetypes and it's so
predictable and so
i came as a skeptic too to begin with
but when i hear people saying i've heard
it so much linda goodman i want to send
her checks like
you've changed the whole world around
astrology she did such an impact
because she wrote so well and she did it
at the moment in the 60s when there was
five planets and aquarius it was the
aquarian age
entered in the 60s we don't really name
that oh
really i thought that was just happening
it happened at the beginning it was
almost the foreshadowing think about it
everything went crazy there were
literally five to six to seven planets
in aquarius in the 1963 64 62.
so that was an era where the openness of
throw away your bras throw away your
money do open relationships remember
that
were you born no you weren't even born
no you're so cute in 82. i know i feel
like a time travel machine
like i remember when were you born i'm
not going to tell
i'm way i'm in my 60s i'm way older than
i look all right pretend i'm way older
than i do yeah you're looking far
younger than that
and and because i was alive during that
time i can tell you that astrology
came into the zeitgeist consciously but
it's been around
there are books written in the beginning
of time they kept track of the
hieroglyphics and these architecture
these archetypes that describe our
psyche and carl jung here's the punch
line
he was a psychologist he was the
original psychiatrist with freud
carl jung freud and carl jung was an
astrologer he didn't tell people
didn't tell people and he was quoted to
say psychology will be a dinosaur
science until it includes astrology
so it was there but it got so discolored
like it turned into this like
cheap dippy parlor trick or so i don't
know i don't know what happened
religion said do not go to those
those seers and somehow it turned into
black magic and it got turned away
so i'm i feel like you're helping me
revive this lost science as
is trevor and shaylene and the people
that i know who are in the public's eye
who are saying
and my gift is talking english i don't
like to talk about neptune squares your
venus in the seventh house opposite mars
i
think but you know what that means but i
don't ever i do everything i can in the
school
and the way that i teach people is to
please don't do that jargon because it's
my kids have teased me too long like if
you do one more of those sentences so
i've
translated into english that's so
wonderful
um i feel like and i interviewed another
person he's a
he's an astrophysicist neil degrasse
tyson and
um he does the same thing for for
that world that is so hard to understand
and puts that into english so
i appreciate that and i'm going to need
it in a lot of english and probably a
lot of people are too because it is
confusing even as many things as i
follow it's like houses in this
and houses and that's in signs and it's
completely
and it looks like a giant piece of pie
like there's 12 pieces to a pie i want
that piece
yeah oh yeah the visual is so
fascinating can you also do the video
wow
yes and then the question is what does
it mean so this is pure science this is
astronomy
well let's go back so you like you said
it's been around for
thousands and thousands and thousands of
years and so when i
look at astrology from a skeptical point
of view
you know i'm like well what does that
really mean but then i i always like
my mind always goes to the fact that
it's been
around longer than like anything it's
always been here look at the egyptians
and understanding the stars
and and and understanding every time
they were in the ocean they had to guide
themselves from place to place it was
always based in the stars
so where did it i mean where does this
come from where does astrology
originate i'm going to say the weirdest
thing but i have to say i trolled a
little bit and saw your little last
interview
i think it was downloaded from a higher
intelligence i'll let you guess what i'm
imagining yeah
like it was brought to us by an
intelligence that's clearly not ours
like it's so airtight it's such a clean
system
i can tell you the timing i can tell you
the personality type and it always works
i came as a skeptic
so the yeah i i was just curious i was
trained as a i have a master's so how
old were you when you started then
i started when i was the first time i
ever had a reading
i was 18 as well oh yeah i was just but
i came with this question mark like is
this real
i have a logical mind which is why i
teach and talk it's so easy i have
a lot of earth so i'm super practical
but over the years now
there's no question and so i kept asking
this question like who is so
intelligent psychologically right to
describe these
very distinct personality types with
such clarity the body part
the timing the personality type the way
they'll act in the fight the way they'll
act when they're sad the way that they
want to go approach
money the way they want to go approach
exercise like i could describe by you
giving me a character exactly how
they're going to
and it's always accurate it's like being
psychic
it has shades of psychic i i would say
yes it does have shades of pink you're
so cute
it does have shades of being psychic it
does lead into
a right brain function it starts off
that's what i was saying it's pure
science
like this is astronomy this is not
debatable when you were born
the sun and the moon were in the same
spot you know that you were born under a
dark sky
so i automatically know you're an
introvert even though you're a double
aries and you've got all this fire party
you you were born under a completely
dark sky
so i immediately know oh she likes going
in
i had a personality test done this year
and um not just like one you take online
but a professional one where there's you
know an hour session afterwards to go
through it
and so um in it there's three different
categories
one is your social setting and how you
are in casual situations and then
there's another category
of sort of your work scenario so
more of your decision making skills
sort of in business how you operate
your control is what they call that
category and then the final category is
your affection category which is your
deep relationships and your romantic
relationships
and interesting in the social setting
my there's two different parts within
each three
and there's an expressed amount and then
there's a wanted
amount and it's a scale from zero to
nine so
in a social setting which is casual
don't know you very well
small talk i express
a two out of nine and you know how much
i want
zero zero i don't
i can take vacations by myself i like to
be alone a lot
that's fine i hear i can totally yeah
how so how do you because it shows up
with your son
this is one of the quotes that i use
when i teach whatever house the sun
falls in
describes the whole theme of the chart
because that house is lit up
like whatever part of the sky the sun
was in so when you were born it was just
getting passed to the horizon it was
going down
and it was in the house of the loner so
that's funny because you're so the rest
of your chart is unbelievably social
like
your social skills and your grace and
your charm
and everyone falls in love with you
because you've got all this little libra
and you look so cute we can dress you up
but there's a part of you going frills
for fake but but but it still looks good
but your secret sauce is can we go now
but you can't tell by looking so you
present to the world with libra rising
with this very open mind and
graciousness and social skills
and then the sun whatever house the sun
is in yours is in detail
like you are very precise not most areas
have as much precision
as you need is that true uh yeah give me
an example what you'd mean by precision
it would be everything from how you
would dress to how you'd want things put
in the right spot so how you would
decorate to like yeah
like don't so there's a detailist you're
right like
especially i knew this a long time ago
when i first
have started having houses and even just
a little thing of like pictures being
straight
it was like had to be like exactly
straight
this is sixth house sun but so you do
have the that's one flavor the house of
the sun describes the theme of someone's
life the precision
the desire to serve people like a very
strong instinct to be in service
from health food to information to
supplements to knowing how to help
people and give them
that's a big part of your chart but the
other thing is with the sun and moon in
aries there's a party that's like can
you just leave me alone
like nate not most aries want to be
alone you do
you've got this pull you really have a
split chart one half you so social and
so fun
and so light and the other hard part is
so intense
and so detailed and so precise yeah it's
like a ping pong game
so then it's very interesting so then
now let's go to the control settings so
where does that so where does that show
up in my chart with
wanting like i'm you know to be able to
make decisions quickly
be assertive be confident type a lead
the way
oh well that's all ares hello yeah you
just described an aries
i am the first one of the zodiac i am
bursting through springtime
are you ever pretending i'm you oh yeah
yeah yeah but i'm very good at being
able to have you seen those funny videos
where i act out all the signs uh-huh
i love being aries they're like my
favorite so they initiate
they start they have so much chi they're
fearless
they like to be scared they like to push
they think about spring where it's
bursting like your energy burst and then
oopsies
i didn't like you can't help yourself
there's times where you just
stick your foot in your mouth and then
it's just that's 100 right i call it
diarrhea of the mouth much less elegant
than what you call it but
but spring honestly there's no way that
you like honesty for you
is your medicine like be real and be
straight i love aries
women it's funny that's what i do
whenever i say
i bark that's what my friend stacy tells
me who also
loves this stuff and um she she says to
me
your honesty i love it and some people
don't love it
but my honesty will always be always
rooted in just the truth that i see in
you
right believing in you right there's
another thing that happens where
um like when i go work out with people
i'm told i'm a workout bully oh my god
competitive
yeah but i believe in them so much so
i'm like come on yeah 15 seconds left do
three more you know there's
yeah you are inspirational to push us
past our edge because for you you can't
imagine
first just think about spring yeah
you're like why would you not want to
burst
so let's go let's go back because this
is important like well this is fun for
me and this is all about
you know me and and i love it i love it
but but when you talk about let's say
that social part even to go back to that
and how
it was dark night and it was like the
the sun
and sun we're blocking each other we're
blocking each other so
how does that apply like what's the
how do i believe that matters good
question so for the rest of us it's
unusual you're born under a new moon
that so the full moon is always like
today the sun and moon are opposite each
other
and that's a big fat full moon because
you can see it it's the sun is over here
not taking any light away
so the moon's in full glory when you
were born the sun and moon were standing
right next to each other and they were
blocking each other
so what it suggests the moon talks about
our inner world it's the night time
it's the emotional body it's what
happens when your eyes are closed it's
that feeling thing we can't describe
but your son blotted out there's no way
for you to feel your feelings
everything gets smushed so you can't
distinguish the rest of us who have
our moon everyone can listen to look
where your moon is and you'll find out
how you respond
emotionally it gives us a clue your moon
your emotional body gets blocked out by
your ego they're so one the same
that when you feel something there's no
medium there's no objectivity there's no
com impulse control you're like i don't
know i just had to say it i
i'm feeling it this is so true like
there's no kind of sort of like the rest
of us live with
you're like fully impacted so we have
the moon most of us somewhere else
that has a different dialogue than our
personality our ego our sun signs
there's something going on
sometimes it's conflicted the emotions
are being secretive for example
and the sun is very verbal that's a
confused personality type
yours they're both so blunt they're both
so honest
they're both so excited yeah they both
you run energy through your body
how does that matter like how can i'm
sitting at home and i'm going okay but
who cares that the sun and the moon were
right there and
how does that really apply to me and
give me like
the tangible like the is it the
energy that comes from the sun and if
it's blocked you literally
don't get the energy you need in that
sort of
thousand now you're making stuff up this
is so mercury in pisces
no you get the energy you need they're
both fully operative but it makes you
introverted all you have to think about
is you were born if we were living in
early times where there was no lights it
just happened in california where i was
the lights were out for five days and i
kept saying this is what it was like in
the olden days
you had it like when there was no moon
to reflect you were inside the
tribe you were inside your little cabin
you're inside your little tent because
you couldn't see you were born under a
dark sky so your
impulse your personnel the translation
is you like being inside
you like being alone you require
darkness you want to be insular and feel
that's not true for someone who's got a
full moon who's like no
we're having a party and it's bizarre i
wish i could answer the question
of what this is my favorite question why
is it so impactful
that the planets will be i mean don't go
there yes but it's a really good
question that's the part that the
skeptic wouldn't need
and i appreciate them no it's a it's an
abstract it's just like
you can't see love but you absolutely
know it's true
good analogy you can't see gravity but
you don't doubt that if we tip that over
it's done
we can't see electricity we still don't
know why electricity works there's still
a mystery
so this takes us to the mystery and we
have logical people that go
no if you can't well i'm sorry then you
can't do love
if you don't want to stay in love and be
able to deal with that we're going to go
past logic now and go in this room
called the right brain
if you don't want to hang out with me
good have fun by yourself that is a
fantastic argument
i love that it reminds me of a movie
called contact did you ever see contact
totally uh where the where that was the
exact
analogy used to prove something um
uh what's her name uh yes jody yes yes
uh she needed to prove that everything
was able to work because she was a
scientist and matthew mcconaughey
was the was the religious sort of
feeling guy and he's like you know did
you love your dad and she's like of
course and he said
prove it that's when you go i love that
oh i'm going to steal that
yeah but that is such a great like that
sort of reminds me of and i totally
that's another thing i i believe you
don't need to convince me
i believe it because i feel it in my
intuition but that's what i'm trying to
say your moon is so connected
you live in your moon it's so directly
connected
you've got an honesty machine that lives
in your body
so when you get a feeling you're like
got this yeah and when they try to get
you off you're like no
because double aries now the libra i'm
curious about because you have another
party that's like well
i'll see it from your point of view does
that happen where you suddenly get over
there instead of inside
sure um uh i mean i
it's funny i've been taking so many
personality tests lately
um but there's this one where i
interviewed a girl
a lady who writes books her name is
gretchen rubin and she wrote a book
called the four tenancies
and i there's four of them and i'm an
upholder so i'm not going to go into
long
lung understanding of the book but it
basically says that i uphold all of my
own
rules and and goals and i also uphold
yours too
so when someone tells me something and i
care about them and respect them and
trust them
i do second guess i'm like wow well
maybe i'm
i mean i might respond like an aries
right i might be like what
no and then i'm like wait that's the
ping-pong game
maybe i should listen and that is your
life lesson
in your life lessons relationship how to
stay on your side of the court without
going over there to theirs
and then coming back like you really do
have ping pong in your chart where one
half of you wants nothing more than
harmony at all costs yeah like it
matters so much for you to feel like
you're really connected
and the other side's like can we just be
alone for a little while i need to go
run
so what is that so that's the aries
libra so the aries so the
the aries is the sun and moon and libra
rising right on saturn you have a lot
you've got three planets in libra
you don't just have so this you've got a
real ping-pong game and the gift of that
is
what's true of both of them is the
leader like
in the end you're like i got this like
you cannot have someone tell you what to
do
at a certain point oh my god at a
certain point you're like no no no
i got this even as a kid i'm sure your
mom would tell us like you were the
little girl with your little hand on
your hip going no
yeah but i can be convinced by someone i
care you get lost
in a relationship by giving yourself
away yeah a hundred percent and then go
back you'll feel like you're in the
relationship and you're so merged and
then suddenly you're like i need space
and then you're back in again no no no i
want to be in love i love you oh i gotta
go find my bedroom
you need a room of your own funny
there's a chapter in my book
um that i wrote a couple years ago
called pretty intense just call this
show
because it describes him pretty well and
there's a chapter on
creating your woman cave you need a
woman cave so i had one in my last house
and i loved it i
it helped me really understand what i'm
truly interested in and my hobbies
and it was so my own space and so i have
been working on another one in this
house that i live in now and or one of
them and
you know i i just feel like it's so
important to have my own
space right because you do this thing
where you go and you merge with people
and you're harmonizing you're really
good at relationship
and then all of a sudden you lose
yourself so you've got to go back over
here it's
it's a ping pong and it's a duality that
you live with
so what is the part that i need to work
on well i think it's being honest with
yourself about
do i want to be in partnership at this
level right now like you have to keep
tracking keep monitoring this is true
for everyone but you really have it
how much am i giving myself away am i
giving up my taste buds am i giving up
my style
am i compromising at any level because
you want to you want to harmonize
and then come back to yourself and go uh
oh am i being too selfish am i being too
independent did i just pull away am i
making myself
can you feel that it's true for everyone
but you really have it and
when the balance is in place of
independent
dependency or codependent and or
interdependent like
doing both because at worst you could be
a codependent of
really wanting oh my god so needing a
partner and then party is like
are you kidding me i don't need any you
know you go between those two and in the
middle land
in my book called the missing element
you figure out where's my observer like
let me be aware which is what you're so
obviously fascinated
by distinctions like let me be aware of
these different parts of myself so i can
navigate
yes and let me tell my partner intimacy
is into me i see
the more i know me the closer i can get
to you
so when i tell my partner oh listen
deborah i have so much energy
you'd really want me to go for a yoga
class right now or i'm going to get re
like i know enough now about myself
exactly what i need to do
to keep my fluid energy going but if i
go off my rhythm
because i'm dancing with the other and
oh it doesn't matter if i do yoga
or i don't have to go for my run then
all of a sudden i'm off center
and my observer's suddenly going you
know what you're pissed off at him no
you lost your rhythm right that's your
thing in this life
how do i keep my awareness on of the
other and the self
without getting caught in either extreme
right right just relate to that so much
i do
feel such um a deep yearning for
the deepest truest kind of love and um
like being in sync with each other and
understanding and
having there be literally no tension
like there's nothing there's no tension
i can't i have tension
you're a master at relationship your
chart has the potential
to really do divine union wow and that's
the deepest cause i'll tell my boyfriend
i'm gonna tell him you have because your
saturn
isn't is in libra like your life lesson
saturn tells us what your life lesson is
okay
that's the my system when i teach the
most important planet of saturn
it gives me all the clues of what did
someone sign up for and you're in a
major change as we sit here like
your chart is actively being opened the
seven year cycle
this year right about the winter coming
close to us
of making some big decisions
life-changing decision you'll remember
this year as a significant marker
you should see her face could you see
your face yeah i can they're punched in
real tight on it
well it's it's okay because i mean
that's you know sometimes that can be
scary
because you're like well it could go
wrong but it could go right
but there's really no wrong do you get
scared
um yeah so i look very far forward like
i think they're
i feel as though people tend to either
look back a lot or they look forward a
lot living in the presence very
challenging i think for anybody
except a monk sitting on a hill with
nothing to do but be present
um but i'm a look forward person so i
create a lot of attachments
to outcomes to how i see everything
going
to a relationship to a job to a company
i look really far forward which helps me
be motivated
and get somewhere but if it needs to go
somewhere different
than where i've been looking i can take
a while to
let go of it i used to think i was a
little slow or something was wrong with
me because i'm
so here and now and then i found out it
was the high road that it was the gift
of a meditator because i would i get so
simple
i'm so in the present that it's a
problem when people start future pacing
i'm like wow that's
interesting you're already out there
it's a different as you say it's a
different sensibility
yeah i find it fascinating to what this
is my favorite thing
how we are all so different and how we
dance together so i hire someone
to do what i can't do and they count on
me to bring them into the now
do you do consulting for companies to
hire the right people to balance
that is the highest road of a you're
such a futurist that's the highest road
of astrology is
in my company which i have over 30
employees wow
i look at all their charts i know all
their charts and when that when i can
see the charts about to change i'm like
back up the bus let's review this are
you sure this is what you want to do
and so it keeps the company in such a
happy place because i would
high vibes for day forever yeah so we
keep the energy up because people are in
the right seat
and they're in their natural flow and
they're not doing what they think they
should be doing
but what they're actually good at
so then how does this apply so obviously
then you go to something that is so much
more intimate which is the relationship
part
and so you've got one person that is
into astrology and understands things
and then one person actually you know it
doesn't even matter whether one person
is or isn't how do you use astrology
to exist and and
is that even possible or is it also
science to you don't exist together like
i know that you think you do
but you are not looking at this thing
clearly well i always say cupid doesn't
know astrology
and she could care less about her
eyesight she just pulls the thing back
and you're in a
designed spiritual agreement like that
cupid's works for some high force where
you have karma together we're going to
shoot this and when you get that first
oh my god i just fell in love then
after the chemistry wears off because it
lasts sometimes for a week sometimes for
10 years we don't know how long but at
some point you're going to bump okay
then you come to the straddle she goes
oh my goodness compatibility
let's talk about this this guy wakes up
early in the morning laughing with the
phones
and the music and the radio and you like
to wake up softly so
that's a problem oh this guy loves to
eat meat and he's really into that
french fries and you're a vegan uh
that's a problem so we begin to look at
the practical but
when you have a karmic agreement with
someone
who doesn't matter you have an agreement
and that's going to be a time period
there's always an expiration date or not
okay that i wish we could see like
that's my secret feel like if i could
just tell someone
this is going to last for this long but
you can't so so and
so in this libra rising my car in this
life my karmic life is relationships
that's part of my final phase of this
cycle of healing is relationship so
right is that what you told me
yes so are you saying that
you know this is your entire lifetime
fulfillment like you're going to
you're a pure harmonious exchange you
named it
your highest road is to have not a hair
get between you
yeah that's like ecstasy for you yeah it
is like
i mean i i can okay like
so this morning i'm like hey babe how's
it going you know
and he's just kind of like is something
is everything okay
and he's just really quiet and i can
just feel there's just a like
something in between us like there's a
disconnect and it i can
that energy is like such a feeling that
either it's in
resonance and it feels so simple and and
pure and good and
in sync or it feels like
the only thing that i'm worried about if
it's out of sync it's the only thing i
care about
and so it's so funny yes it becomes this
big
oh my god it's the only thing that i can
think about and i will
and i libra my reaction is so big
normally like it can't be like oh okay
it's like no seriously this isn't fair
and so i'm like you can't
i'm like what's going on what's going on
i'm like it needs some more
communication about if something's going
on
if it's not me just say so if you need a
minute like i need some communication
and so when there was an acknowledgment
of like yeah i'm thinking about some
things and i don't want to talk about it
i'm like you know just tell me that even
just knowing that helps me because
if i can't if i can't i have to learn
how to trust my intuition
and and know be able to have that
confidence of sensing
your situation to be in relationship
with you're like a lie detector test
yeah the winds change
the mood changes and you're like double
barriers double errors i'm on alert
so that's important for you to know stay
on your side of the fence a harmonious
relationship is letting people
have their space enough to enough
enough to trust that you are holding
down the ground
see we can't lean on someone in
relationship the strongest relationships
and i've been privy and i've studied
them because i'm libra rising so i've
been fascinated by this
when you meet someone who's
independently self-sufficient and
sovereign
and one plus one their other partner
turns into three thousand because
they together make this giant energy
field but if one plus one
this one affects them and it diminishes
because suddenly that one is so affected
by the other they're not holding their
own
it becomes a distracting game now the
good news is your partner is willing to
take care of you
but in a perfect world libra rising what
you would learn
is that you've got this their mood that
quality of whatever's going on you can
definitely do your inventory and check
it out
but it should never take you into that
space of distraction
which i know libras we get so distracted
because you know you've got the
relationship
you're in charge whatever happens you've
got you at the end of the story you're
so good double aries
uh you're saying on my own like i've got
me like no problem
exactly this doesn't work no problem
bingo and when you know that's true you
can leave room for your partner to do
their
whatever they do because i love to use
this line men are stupid and women are
crazy
so they can't track us all the time and
we're a little emotionally uh
um sensitive that's a nice way to put it
it's just the nature of the hormones
that the nature has not
astrology then no it's mars and venus
but it is estrogen and testosterone and
their nature is to push and to be
disconnected they have a different
function
in their brain even and we're all about
yum yum yum so it's a two different
worlds
but the wisdom of the woman is that
she's fully self-sufficient
and she loves being in a relationship
but she can watch him go through a mood
and same for him by the way
let him watch us go through something be
aware but don't interrupt
to the point until you know do you need
to talk like i feel like something's
going on just checking in
and then you go and then you go okay
well you know what i feel you
but i don't want to let this interrupt
anything to do with my day
labor's at their worst feel other people
so much it's what we're just saying
they lose their strength and they begin
to blend
and merge and the next thing you know
they're not having a good day because he
wasn't that wait i'm confused
how did that become contagious good
question
have you been able to uh accurately
maybe you don't tell them but can you
make assessments of relationships
and say like yeah that one's probably
not going to make it
or do you look at i'm have you been is
there any of those scenarios
where even if it's an internal thought
where you're able to identify based on
charts
well i have a friend that i worked with
for many years a colleague of mine that
he would tell people you're not going to
work
i love that he was that blunt and honest
i am not that person and i am the
hopeless endless optimist so i'm on the
process of assisting people
but you know this when you go to a
wedding i mean everyone knows there are
certain couples you meet you go
i can smell something fishy and then you
go to a wedding you're like oh my god
that soul contract i i perform weddings
and one of the last weddings i went to
i was giving the ceremony and her last
bow to him which we didn't see coming
was
and i vow that i will come find you one
lifetime is not enough makes me want to
cry when i say it
she was like this is not enough i love
every minute of being with you and i
will find you
that name everywhere in the room like
now that's true love like
we were in that's the whole thing was
but some couples yes
it's a timeline and do i tell them no no
i mean i'm blunt
and i'm known for really strong honesty
moon in aries and
i respect that we learn our lessons the
strangest ways
i mean that is just embarrassing humans
how we learn uh let's get a frying pan
and then let's break my heart
and then let's see how long it will last
before i wake up and go ooh
this isn't working and it happens all
the time so you talked about soul
contracts
talk explain more of what that would be
to someone who doesn't know it's cupid
again
she has this agreement that she works
for this guy called
fate and she comes in and she gives you
an agreement that was made there's a
soul contract there's beings i have this
theory
there's some people you can't get rid of
so they keep finding you
whether it's the dog or it was your
mother or was your first boyfriend they
show up again
and you know when you meet someone you
go i mean this happened for trevor hall
and i who i have this crazy
soul contract with like you meet someone
you're like i think
i know you and then it shows itself it
proves itself out and you've got
durability the friendship endures and
lives through so much
and then there's others where it's a
short-term thing and that's a soul
contract
but it's a short version so you know in
your heart of hearts i think
it doesn't take long if you can listen
i have tattooed on my arm the words
listen and silent
you've got to be silent and they hate
the same letters so you have to be
silent enough
to go into yourself to go do i really
feel like this relationship is
supporting me
and am i really supporting you and you
know in your heart of hearts when you're
like oh my god we
i'm so sick of how much we bump and edgy
and i've done the therapy but it won't
work well go to the astrologer and
they'll tell you
this is a difficult i can say that very
clearly this is a difficult relationship
the karmic agreement came with some
overview of
a memory something's continuing here or
this one's
you guys get along so well and you've
done this three times before in the most
recent lifetimes and
obviously you worked out how easy it is
you know that you know this in your
heart everyone knows
it's so obvious but we just can't tell
ourselves we're not very honest because
we live in the illusion
that we don't really trust our intuition
we pretend
logic is what's ruling this place this
place is not ruled by
logic it's the craziest plan i've ever
been on i was sitting on an airplane and
i said that the guy next to me was an
engineer and he said
where else have you been and i was like
i can't explain it to you but
i i know this planet is a very unique
and difficult
way of operating it's not logical but
we're taught
in school to do everything on logic in
that so
when we go back to love and the right
brain
and trusting there's deep knowing and
we're allowed if willing
to slow it down learn meditation
listen to a song and watch your heart
journal and read what you've written
read it don't just write it and when
you've said it 45 times i'm so
frustrated i'm so frustrated you go i
think i'm frustrated
and then you go see an astrologer or a
counselor and you go i can't get out
the super glue's got can you is there
any solvent you can show me how to erase
this because
this karmic agreement is not working but
i can't undo it
and then someone will help you so it's
possible to
absolutely cancel a contract oh yeah
and it becomes obvious like you are
honestly in a moment in your chart that
i'm sitting here
where you have an opening a significant
opening where your life's going to
change
in these next or you already know this
but opportunities are coming your way
strong in the next and i hate to say
this but i saw your sweeties chart
it's true for him too so that's
auspicious we call that auspicious i
love that word
timing occurs that's divinely
orchestrated
and if you're wise enough and you're in
the sink you're in flow
then you're in the movement of your life
and you're following it but when you go
bumpy bump
and things go off you know we all know
but it's just so hard to admit cause
we're so scared
that's why i wanted to know miss racecar
driver what scares you
like can you identify what's scary
i mean i when i was younger i would have
i said
failing and i'd still say that to be the
case
i'm actually yeah i mean it's just
really not
not being successful or not excelling at
what i choose to do
and now is that subdued since you've
been sick have you would you call
yourself successful it's a hard thing to
answer
yeah yeah yeah i have been yeah
um but the drive to continue that in
some other way
is totally there oh i see so the impulse
that concept yeah
yeah to be i guess my my goal would be
to be
not to take anything away from racing i
don't want someone to start listening
and then i don't want to lose them
um because of the beginning of this but
i hope that i'm known for something else
someday
like i hope that people remember me as a
race car driver as an afterthought
not to take away from racing but to
speak volumes about whatever i do next
like this like opening the door of
people's minds
of bringing in fascinating characters
and asking the best question libra you
know who was a double leader was johnny
carson
they asked the best questions that's
what they're known for spontaneous
and so is sting double libra spontaneous
openness
which is what you display and
fascinating with everything to do with
science people everything yeah i mean
your your interest probably goes
all over the place yeah that's a very
profound gift you're giving us
the gifts the the guests are really wide
a wide wide array of guests everything
from you know someone like yourself
to an um an astrophysicist to
scientists doctors musicians musicians
actors um you name it like just it's
racist athletes you name it and what
made you do this
i'm very interested in the human story
i'm really interested in the human
story of growth like i want to know
some of these are like this is a little
bit more educational based because i
believe that growth also is being
educated
like you can't hearing something new
opens you up and opens the door it's
like you can't make someone think
something else
but never underestimate the power of
planting a seed and that's what i want
to do with the science
and with the experts like yourself
and the doctors is to plant that seed of
like well maybe i need to do these
things so maybe i don't get into their
story quite so deeply because
what they are here to bring as
information is
is really important um and so
but the rest of them are about the human
story i love and how they grow
that's the subtitle in my book it's
called the missing element compassion
for the human condition
like what do we do with these humans and
how do we understand
do you know that you have no earth in
your chart did anyone tell you that yet
what does that mean then so that's my
book the missing element you take
a personality test in the middle of the
book and you figure out it means that
when it comes to practicality
money organization structure getting
things done on time being executed
part of you is either hates that or is
really good at it which isn't
i'm not a detailed girl bingo so when it
comes to details yeah and it comes to
spreadsheets yeah when it comes to
instruction manuals you're like oh no
please it's like brain dead to me you
can seriously feel brains
now i'm giving you a line to take home
you have no earth in your chart
so you need to bring in people that can
help you with earth
or you consciously cultivate it it's
totally counterintuitive
it will feel unnatural but it will
balance i described four wheels in a car
water air earth and fire the four
personality types and you've got one
tire that's down
so you've got to figure out how am i
going to keep that salad and what do i
need in my world
to keep me grounded so it's either
another person to fill in the
fill the void or you need to cultivate
it yourself there you go
and it's possible you're saying 100 even
though it's not in
my yes charts it's not in me i can still
cultivate not everyone can purchase or
buy someone to help them ground or clean
or organize
yes you can definitely go learn it it's
a skill set like cooking food and buying
you know details and learning how to do
spray it's going to feel like
like you're crooked like how do i do
this yeah what is that process
it's a real deliberate effort like
that's part of my school
in the very first class we figure out
what your missing element is and then we
give you homework to go do the very
thing
you don't want to do but then what
happens is like let's say it's water and
they haven't cried in years because they
lost their emotional
i say go watch sad films like make those
tear ducts
go through the four elements and then
explain like what that
if you have it or don't have it just
kind of understand so water
which you have you've definitely got
water here in this chart your um is
sensitivity it's tears
uh-huh i cry regularly yeah you cry
regularly
it's tears it's emotions it's um
intuition
it's the invisible world water is more
of the emotional intuitive
quiet sensitivity you have it sensing
people reading people
loving to be alone really valuing being
by the water being
in the water having a gift for being um
the caretaker the healer
who come over here and cuddle with me
i'm going to give you a little yes and
sexuality the yum yum factor which i
know
is in your chart don't say anything just
yet the deliciousness of
that's very water if you're missing it
you can't feel you've lost that
sensitivity it's gone to ice
and it freezes if it's too much you're
depressed and you're addicted because
you just can't stand how much you feel
so you shut the whole thing down by
becoming just like disassociated yeah
so physical touch is for sure in a
relationship my
love languages physical things that's
you jupiter's and scorpio you
love that jupiter tells me what you love
not sex everybody so relax i mean
there's some of it but it's
holding my hand it's putting your arm
around as soon as you're kissing me
just something physical just a touch
like literally
i'm like babe you could dissolve so many
arguments if you just hugged me he's
like how can i hug you right now and
when we're doing that you know if you
could just get rid of 75
of the problem or that's water yeah
that's your job okay that's the jupiter
is what you love and you love water so
that's for sale
so if it's down it means you can't feel
if it's working
overworking it means you feel too much
and the middle is wisdom
intuition dalai lama's double water
being able to meditate is the high road
of water
next comes air air is the communicator
it's you are you and i both libra
air is thinking and talking and
communicating and reading and
they're interested in every single topic
and their favorite thing is relationship
and being in harmony oh yeah oh my god
so they have people's phone numbers and
they have their little phone number
they're doing this thing all the time
and they're texting and they're on
social media and they
have their friends and they're reading a
great book and they want to share the
great book with you this is oprah
error fascinating with all content
all colors of people and wanting to talk
and communicate water's like shh
can you guys be quiet and just touch me
aaron's like no no no we're going to
tell stories we've got a lot of stories
to tell
i'm interested in yours and mine now i'm
all confused so they're airheads
at their worst they're airheads they're
like i can't remember where i was going
do we write it down
that's my friend stacy we actually
sitting here we recorded a few episodes
where
um we just riff on a word like literally
so the word that we did a couple
episodes ago was grow
um that came out and it's because it's
my word of the year
but we just talked for a half an hour
about the word grow that's so you that's
so air
air is the element of riffing on words
and finding humor and doing
wit and feeling like they're
entertaining themselves by the hour by
the sound of their own voice so
when there's so two people to talk to
it's even better because you can't
really talk to yourself well you can't
but you shouldn't so when there's a
dialogue then you have the air social
animals
very fun to play with if they're missing
air they don't want to socialize and
they don't want to talk
and they find themselves non-verbal and
they find themselves by themselves
they're not socializing at all
if there's too much air they talk so
much you're like
is there an off button on this person
like why are we talking about the
temperature of where
africa is and how it's going to affect
we all know somebody like that airhead
so at their worst or extreme at their
best they are in the middle
they're the eloquent speaker that you
listen to their words and it's poetic
and you think how they put those words
together
or you read what they wrote and you're
like these words are so compelling i've
been drawn in
so that's the high road of error yeah
it's one of your favorite things
is a really good communication and a
really good conversation welcome to
podcast that's eric yeah i just
i that's my discipline is to listen but
the reason why they you know people ask
why
i also own a winery they're like why why
do you why do you why'd you make wine i
said cause i like to drink it like why
do you have a podcast i'm like i like to
talk
but my discipline is to listen but it's
also so
information like it's also very much
there's talking but that's my challenge
well that's libra it's the art of
listening in silent
like listening to someone without your
own voice of your head inside this is
the art of true listening
if i can hear your words without
interrupting you or making me two
sentences and actually hear what you've
said and repeat it i know i'm listening
it's one of my favorite things to do
so that's air people at their best
they're great listeners and they're a
great communicator worse they talk and
talk and talk as my friend said
they talk all night they talk about
nothing then we have earth
earth people are the most grounded loyal
steady
you have none of this steady addy loyal
they love money they love saving things
they love
organizing they have lists for
everything they keep everything in their
specific order
and they have a passion for working like
it's their favorite thing they have to
be in productivity
or getting results to justify their
existence so the whole world revolves
around productivity
efficiency and then they complain i'm
the only one cleaning up around here i'm
the only one you're like
well when i went to clean you got mad at
me because i put the forks in the ups
like your they love control so earth
people are very solid
they're very grounded they're very loyal
but at worst they're very picky and
they're judgmental and they're
perfectionist
so if you don't have any earth in your
chart you tend to not care about all
those practical details and they can
fall away
if you have too much earth you're so
preoccupied with it you forget to have
fun
because they're working all the time so
in the middle is this beautiful art
of beauty enjoying the moment
celebrating work
finding the work that you love and doing
it but not because you should
or you have to because you really enjoy
practicality it's your pleasure to be of
service
so earth is a very i love these people
they're like the steady eddies in the
world like the grounded friend that you
have you go to their house and they
always have the same dinner and they
repeat themselves and yeah
everything's very similar the smell
everything's repetitive that's the clue
of earth
they repeat and they like routine oh
yeah yeah no we're not you're i have
i i think someone else that's true but i
i think that
my ride or die i think she's i think
she's earth and you love those people
the details and the editing
oh yeah oh my god you can never have to
wonder if they'll be on time oh
right no early earth i had a teacher how
to be a little less early yes you want
to like relax a little bit yes
and then fire's the last category this
is your sweetie blunt and honest and
physical and constantly moving and is
there an off button and loud and
indulging and eating and drinking and
it's a party waiting to happen they're
the louder people their volumes cranked
up
they have an intense honesty you have
this oh my god
they can't hold back the impulse control
is not there yeah
they're here to wake us up so fire
people are the ones that you want to say
to them god did you just say that but
they're like oh
sorry like they didn't mean to say it
but it came out impulsively because it's
the part in all of us
that wants to stay awake at all costs
they can't really turn it off
so at worst they're loud they're
impulsive they spend too much they eat
too much there's no off button
if they're done and they don't use their
fire they've lost their sexual urge
they don't have the desire to work out
anymore they don't want to be seen
they don't want the attention so fire is
the element of real joy at best at the
high level
it's inspirational like you feel like
you're around them and you're like oh my
god they're so funny
and we're gonna go have a party now
we're going outside we're gonna jump off
the cliff and then we're gonna have a
trip
they're just courageous race car drivers
they're courageous to do things that
we'd all go no but for fire
they can't stand not doing it so you
have to have all four
the goal of the game is to have all four
wheels balanced if you can't cry
emotionally you're not available right
if you can't speak
use your words you can't do relationship
right if you can't take care of money
and practicality and keep your food and
really know how to
respect the body you're going to get
sick and if you can't have fun and have
orgasms go home
what's the point of life what are you
doing here yeah
um does that make sense the fourth house
yeah it's ancient
it makes sense it's a it's the balance
right it's not quite like a
it's not like a yin and yang balance of
two things it's a much more
of um a life balance right it's a
foundation it's a square
it's a box it's how you keep the ground
level by being
able to do all four of these so what are
your what would you recommend for people
if nobody if somebody hasn't done
anything
any hasn't even touched the world of
astrology
what do you recommend for them to do
next well that's what i did in my book i
didn't put any astrology in the book i
just did the four personality types
so people could actually learn the
simple basics without getting
overwhelmed then once i get them into
like oh i'm so yeah what then you go you
take my class i have this
thing you've done tonight so annoying
you've done lots of classes you've been
teaching people a lot lately i've been
seeing
well i'd give free readings and free
sessions online but the school itself is
online
six weeks there's only ten people in the
room it's really cool
and you study your chart i mean trevor
did all of them you go into your chart
and you do just bit size bits like it's
not complicated
because i teach like at a fourth to
sixth grade level but then you
do that yes but then you do the
therapeutic i give you prompts
like tell me about your like you for
example your thought
this is very important in astrology how
does the mind work
that's mercury you know in all buddhism
everything is you know this
what you think is what you become it's
like thoughts become things i say that
all the time
it's so true so if i can figure out how
your thought process works and i can
turn your observer on and yours is
interesting
you have this vast open mind which is a
little confusing
because you're open to everything and
you get feelings like your boyfriend in
the morning like
your mind is an antenna system which is
not the best placement for mercury it's
in a water sign
so your thoughts come with your emotions
my thoughts come with earth i'm like i'm
going to repeat water's wet
air is light earth is heavy fire's hot
like i do but yours is like i'm all over
i'm just interested in this and
oops what did i say so you've got to
really handle how do i monitor my mind
and once you know that about yourself
you can say oh that's my mercury in
pisces it goes all over the place
thank god my aries is here to keep me on
task
because if we left you alone too long
you'd be interested in everything
[Music]
yeah it's true yes um so
so what would so what would someone do
so they could get your book they
understand their personalities
they take level one okay or the other
option is i have a platform called
the star community.com have you seen
that for 22
a month you can just study one sign in
depth every month of the year
by the end of the year you've learned
how it is when the moon is in that sign
what's it like
you get like a cheap shortcut to how can
i learn astrology in a really fast way
okay so you mentioned
all the signs and the 12 signs and then
you said the word zeitgeist at the
beginning have you seen the movie
zeitgeist
you know that was a long time ago yeah
yeah i saw the entrance i didn't know
why i have to be honest
because i've got a lot of fire i didn't
watch the whole thing did you i did
i've seen a couple times because i
recommend it it's one of those where
you know it dips into everything from
religion to conspiracy theories it kind
of
touches on a few different few different
esoteric thoughts
and one of them that i found fascinating
that has to do with astrology
is like the 12 signs
being the 12 disciples
and they all fit into seasons and like
12 months yeah so oh no this is real
no that's real and then you know the son
of man like the sun is the center
so go ahead and color that up a little i
love that
well it is you said this at the
beginning we talked this is the oldest
matrix that was brought to us by some
very high intelligence
that's trying to remind us that there's
a connection like
i love what you said how dare we think
that this
this is the most arrogant narcissistic
sentence
so clearly there's been an imprint
brought to us and it's continued in the
zeitgeist it's in the collective
that we know that we're from stars we
know the moon has an influence on the
the tides the farmer almanac can
describe when the tide comes up and down
based on the moon we are mostly water
why would that not influence us why are
we of course we're moody
of course we feel the full moon and how
delicious that is and the new moon the
desire to be quiet
and go in because it's a dark sky so we
just don't have language
and that's one of my gifts at the air
sign is to bring language to people to
say listen you have to think about this
you gotta
ask yourself why am i in a mood what
part of my personality is being
distracted right now
is it that i've been doing too much work
and i've lost my boundaries around
practicality
is it that i'm too indulgent emotionally
and i stay here and live here in this
is it because my mind is so confused
error and i can't focus and make
decisions so i'm on the wrong street
is it because i squelched my fire and i
forgot to have fun and now i'm in one of
these grumpy moods all the time
so i'm a very practical person
the zeitgeist is an abstract concept i
love the thought
that there's a collective rhythm or
there's a a
collective thought process that we can
see they've proven this
rupert sheldrake that do you know about
this the hundredth monkey
no the morphogenic field so after a
certain amount of people talk about
something long enough
it becomes true sheldrick you'd love his
work the morphogenic field
so it's not a surprise that carl jung
and freud
entered this word psycho we never knew
about psychology until
pluto was discovered in the 1930s pluto
rules the unconscious
then fast forward there's a group of a
hundred astronomers sitting in a circle
and they decide to demote pluto
they did well they didn't but they think
maybe neil might have been part of that
they tried but it's not so it is a
planet or isn't a planet it is a planet
but what's interesting to me
is you know what it represents in
astrology the unconscious
and the shadow so some astralis these
astronomers got together and decided
they were going to erase the unconscious
good luck with that of course pluto this
is you're going to love this
there are 22 major arcana cars in the
tarot deck did you know that no
so this is the magical what is that the
tarot the
yes very ancient bernard shaw said that
if he was ever on a deserted island he'd
want a tarot deck and a bible because
all the stories okay okay yes so in the
tarot deck i'm saying it wrong my whole
life no
it's okay it's two ways in the tarot
deck there are 22 major arcana cards
they left them in the 15th century they
made this there are 12 for the 12 signs
and there are 10 for the 10 planets they
didn't find pluto until 1930 these cards
were made in the 15th century
and the pluto card is the death card and
there's a group of astronomers sitting
in a circle going let's just do rate
like we want to get rid of death like
we don't want to deal with the truth
which is we are a time
keeper that has an end in the beginning
but for some reason the human psyche
goes death
don't talk how can we be a society that
is so allergic
to the most profound exiting what
happens on your deathbed what happens in
that room just like birth
is a holy land but for some reason these
astronomers got i love that
they were they were demoting pluto we're
going to erase that even though the
tarot deck left exactly
12 signs and 10 planets perfect system
we're deciding we don't want it anymore
because we don't like the unconscious
well good luck with that because
this planet honestly is ruled by the
unconscious
and all psychology is is becoming
conscious of your unconscious
yeah welcome to astrology yeah let me
describe to you your patterns
yeah then you'll make friends with them
and fall in love with you
and will change the unconscious from
being dark and scary to being
awareness and awake and that's my job is
i love putting on
i think you have this too putting on the
light in the dark
and being able to say there's nothing to
be afraid of and all you have to do is
hold the hand of your best friend yeah
to know that you're okay yeah i am
i like i said i've had astrology regions
readings done every year i had one done
at the beginning of the year and
that was one of the things that she said
she said you're an illuminator you
should just turn the light on and just
shine it on something you're an
illuminator
that's a great scene you remembered that
cause that is the truth you're libra
rising you're bringing us light you're
bringing us air
fresh air in a way that's really deep i
like it
you're making my job fun oh well i just
think it's fascinating because
you know we walk through life and
we can be so confused or repeat patterns
all the time and so
you know there's there's there it can be
frustrating
and we don't know why we just keep
meeting the same person or why we keep
you know getting fired for the same
reason or having the same fights with
our fan
whatever it may be and and it can be um
it can be a frustrating process and and
um well actually
what are we here for what are we here
for i'm asking you
what are we here for i love how let's
just do double areas go to the bottom
line yeah
it's a simple answer it's the evolution
of our species
and i have some questions about how
we're doing but you are here to evolve
your soul made a promise that you come
in lifetime after lifetime and you're
doing it
to continually refine the expression of
life showing up inside of you
and devoting yourself with full
commitment which is so obvious of you
to give it everything you have in the
name of kindness
it's kind of simple so evolution and
kindness is my two bookends
and in the middle is your lifetime like
are you growing are you evolving and
are you doing kindness because it's what
dalai lama said the whole thing his
religion is
kindness so i practice this and it's not
easy because i have moon in aries
i get a little pushy and i have a
heritage where people screamed and
yelled a lot it was kind of a loud we
called it the loud family
and i've learned over my lifetime to
breathe
like everything deserves my observer on
like hold on a minute i'm so sorry i
impulsively my moon in aries just
because my company
they tell me they see my moon and ears i
scare people from time to time
but i've gotten really good at saying
i'm so sorry i was just feeling impulse
and by the way what i said was true i
probably just didn't deliver it exactly
the way i should have said it
can you maybe get called sort of gruff
at times yes but we can say i can say
i'm sorry how are you at saying you're
sorry
not so great practice it this is called
i'm so so excited i'm so good i guess
i've gotten really good at it
like i walk straight into difficult
relationships and i say i'm so sorry i
know what i did
this is a crazy story i walked up to
someone i had this crazy meditation
and in the meditation don't ask me i
asked the question weird
if i were to die tomorrow is there
anyone in my world that i have an out
with that i need to clear
who asked that question a great question
okay this is a crazy story
so down comes this person who i hadn't
seen in 10 years and i thought oh god
that's interesting
that same day i'm in whole foods i don't
even know why i'm there
i look at the entrance and in walks this
person and i walk up to him and i say
this is going to be a weird conversation
we're about to have i had a meditation
this morning and i know that you think
that i was instrumental in your divorce
because i was the counselor of your wife
at that time and you heard
a cd of a session we did but i want to
just apologize
i really just want to save you please
forgive me it's not what you think it
was
and by the way you've done a great job
being a dad can i have a hug
and he hugged me hadn't seen him in
years
i walked away and i thought that was a
little bit of magic in the middle of the
day
wow yeah and that was my promise to
myself can
i continually quest kindness is there
anyone i need to ask for forgiveness
now secretly i didn't do anything wrong
but the energetics between us were bumpy
obviously it came into my awareness and
then isn't that a crazy story
so i love the
sort of mindset that energy is not time
and space dependent
which is why people can do readings
psychic readings
and why they get dropped right like that
that stuff can have like the energy is
connected
like the world wide web isn't just on
your computer the web is everywhere
do you believe that a hundred percent
so what are the most important lessons
that you've learned in your life so far
i'm in my 60s that's a big question
i'd say i'm going to go back to that
repetitive thing
thought that kindness that it's
self-kindness that i've fallen i hate to
say this because it just sounds so
contrived
but i've fallen in love with my soul
that i'm gonna cry
that i'm so sincerely committed to
making a difference
and i see my commitment and i really
trust deborah now that didn't happen
until about 15 minutes ago so let's get
clear
there was a long workout that finally
got to the point in my 60s where i can
say i trust me
like i know my heart just makes me so
emotional
so that took a long time of a lot of
mistakes
and being really embarrassed in front of
my kids you know like doing things that
i'm like
like it didn't come that way but in my
life what i've learned
is that i see the sincerity of my heart
and i see the sincerity of your heart
and there's many people you can think
about that you know
it's like the dog like there's not a
mean bone in that being's body
so it gives me a lot of compassion first
it started with me
so when my ego gets triggered of how do
i look like i'm on screen or
how am i doing or where's my success
story or how much
i'm like be quiet what really matters is
i know
in my heart of hearts that i've known
love and i've been loved and if i die
tomorrow
you're making me emotional if i die
tomorrow i could say
life well lived but it's all because
i've learned
honestly how to forgive and that wasn't
natural to me i am not
like some people i i'm amazed at them
something goes wrong
and then the next day they're okay with
it i'm like oh
yeah i'll be right back and it can
honestly it can i'm embarrassed to say
it's taken me years i just recently
there's a jewish holiday called yom
kippur do you know about that holiday
and every year because they lived in
shettles small little groups of people
they couldn't afford to continually have
a gripe between them
so every year on the same holiday they
fast and then they go back to the people
in there's town
and they either write or tell the person
i'm sorry and that's how they keep the
energy clear now that was a theory
it didn't really work but it's a
wonderful theory so this year i did it
this year i did it i do it regularly yes
and that's how that happened with that
guy
i review who and there was one person
that
honest to god year after year i couldn't
forgive her and this year i reached out
and i said i'm
getting older and i want to find that
place inside of myself that is in true
when you ask what did i learn that i'm
truly in a clean space that if i pass
tomorrow
i could say i've got my world clean yeah
you've cleaned
cleaned up your karmic yes debt
exactly so what would you what is your
recommendation and advice for someone
who
is not in that space then you have to
review you
it would be you said it was a transition
so what was that what did that well it's
yom kippur i mean i use that holiday i
really do
but it would be a great gift in the new
year to
stop and make a list who do i have an
out with and where am i at in that
process of being able
especially access you don't have to call
them don't have dinner with them
don't even ever see i wrote that in the
letter to her i don't want to i don't
want to be friends
i'm not reviewing this to be i just want
to say in my own heart of hearts that
yeah i
i am responsible so was this just
something you wrote down i wrote a
letter
do you you wrote the letter where did
the letter go then i actually
emailed her that letter you emailed her
i don't usually but this year for some
reason
i decided to write the letter and send
it because i do i've been i've been
you know it was so hard to forgive and i
was so bumpy inside myself like
i understand my spiritual bible yeah i
understand
but my emotional body was like no i
don't yeah so i had to
get those two you knew your intuition
knew you're like you're not quite there
yet i knew i knew i wasn't there for a
long time and you know when you can't
forgive and then
so if i had to say the answer your
question one of the biggest
gifts in this life that i've learned is
and this is libra by the way is kindness
like
nothing can occur that's that
bad if i take responsibility and say
our karmic agreement put me in a
situation with you and i don't like it
and i don't like you
and i'm willing to take a breath and see
if i can soften this and
objectively neutralize it and that's
what my book is about like turn on the
observer
look back and go what was i supposed to
learn i mean it's such a
it sounds so easy in theory
but if you're honest emotionally
forgiveness
me for me has been a really hard path
right
well i think that's for a lot of people
it's hard there's trauma attachments
there's do you do forgiveness
uh yeah yep i truly believe that
if two people really care i don't think
anyone i really actually think
most everyone's rooted good i don't
think that they're just
there might be a couple of bad eggs out
there that are just true evil
but i don't think so they probably were
taught that if there's a mean dog that
dog got taught when it was a puppy
something like it's not i don't believe
it's there's a root of evil
i do think there's evil really i know
this is a big controversy but i
in my having done the work i've done is
40 years and
you've seen some stuff i've seen some
stuff there are people whose intentions
are not
conscious and they're working for an
unconscious motive that is operative
well what were you just thinking well
who are they working for
well there's a dark force there is an
influence i mean i think it's it's it's
too
pollyanna to imagine this planet is not
having an invisible war
there's an invisible war here there's
something to do with the dark and the
light or the unconscious and the
conscious
that allows negative thoughts to come
through the unconscious
and not be filtered and acted upon i
mean when people are
that dark and they've been operating
with a kind of value system
that is what we would call dark or
working with dark forces
that is evil to be so self-centered
that there's no consideration of the
implications of your behavior
there's a karmic wave nothing in this
planet i think this is a silverman
is not being touched by something else
there is a definite connection
so when you hurt there is a wave there's
an impact
there's a karmic continuation of that
behavior
while you may not see it or understand
it so some people are blessed
beyond measure and you see them and you
see their beauty and you see their skill
set and you see their bodies and
you see their love and you're like how'd
they get there i can promise you
they've worked at this this is not a
first rodeo for you this deep over there
to be so blessed this life is a
reflection of your great
karma that you have given and in this
life you're continuing
and so my question is always when it
comes to evil
what who are they working for and what
was the contract
and how long has that been going on how
long has that been going on
and how do i interrupt it and i've had
the gift at some time in my life of
working with dark energy
i had a whole slew of prostitutes who i
find beautiful
but i could see where they were caught
in a
energetic world where they lost their
integrity and i got to give it back to
them
by not judging them how long do you well
as a curiosity question um how and this
is really to wrap up sort of like
why would you want to know about your
chart why would how would it help you
and and sort of the question being about
let me say it this way when i think
about the challenges in my life
i think to myself i need to get it right
this time because i don't want to come
back and do it again
because i believe in reincarnation great
motive i believe that the cycle just can
if i don't learn it this time and if i
just subject to like allow
something or not face something i'm just
gonna come back and
start all over again energy cannot be
destroyed or created
it continues so keep going you're right
so i don't want to do it again
that's my motive that's beautiful
so what is what what is a recommended
motivation to
like if you were sort of trying to
inspire people to look
deeper into this what would what would
what would convince them
it's like a shorthand it's like a cheat
sheet i can look at your chart and say
here's your propensity
to what will repeat itself this life
what your life lesson is
that if you're not careful and you miss
the boat
um you're coming back so it's a really
powerful
gift of like a running start especially
the 18 both of us
when i knew that i had a dancer she told
me at the very beginning the first
astrologer looked at my chart and i was
studying dance at the time but
i was like really that was so confirming
of course i have a dancer in my chart
i've done it probably
so many lifetimes before and it
validated and gave me permission to
actually be the dancer so there's value
especially for children
to know your child's chart and to
encourage them a double aries like i
would have said to your mom
you let her go you do not hold her back
you're going to have a fight on your
hands she is going to be a wild child
and she needs freedom and the minute you
tell her not to
she will be going straight to what you
said no am i right or am i right
they did a good job they let me move
they let me leave high school at 16
years old
and moved to england by myself to race
so they did a good job exactly so that
was the gift of your good karma
to be involved in a situation where they
supported you but for those of you who
are stuck
people that are feeling like they can't
move or they're in a rut
or they can't figure out how come she's
been so successful all you have to do is
face your fate i call it falling in love
with your fate
fall in love with what you got yeah give
yourself to it
and do your best to be thankful i know
it sounds corny but
i'm so grateful every day like looking
at the ocean
watching the sun come up i wake up in
the morning and watch the sun come up i
live
half the time in hawaii and i am devoted
to that being
that giant unbelievable cosmic creature
that sons
and i give myself to that i devote
myself i do prayers like
use me and then life goes ooh we got a
hot one here
so then they find me then they give me
all kinds of fun things to do next thing
you know i'm having a party
and you're here today and that's how i
found myself
thank you sitting here with you well i'm
blessed for it
i am so grateful you took me deep sister
that was a
definite interview yeah
thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today i hope you
enjoyed it and also
thank you so much trevor hall for the
awesome music if you like what you heard
today
and you want to hear more please click
on the subscribe button
you